and i think ever since you've come into
office things are really looking up you
know gas is up rent is up food is up
everything
no it really has been
a tough first year for you mr president
all right people we are back in business
i'm in studio in the free state of
florida today is may 2nd in the year
2022
i'm still dave rubin this is still the
reuben report direct message we are
still live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv and i got to tell you
people i am happy to be back in studio
the entire team is fired up and ready to
go i gotta show you i think this is our
densest show ever there are words on all
of these pages of paper okay we are
ready to go uh as you know i am back uh
from about 10 days on the road we did a
whole bunch of uh sold out shows all
over the country the first leg of the
don't burn this country
book tour and it was awesome and i just
want to say for every single one of you
that i met that came to a show that took
the one second hug a few of you took the
two second i know you did i know you did
some people would grab me and they
wouldn't let go they go i know i'm
getting an extra second it was just
great being out there it was great
laughing with you guys again and it was
jam-packed let's just get to some images
it was just a great night that's atlanta
with the willy wonka politics michael
malus this is yon mee park this was our
one afternoon show
matinee show in chicago and janmi she
goes from north korea to a comedy club
in chicago illinois it was awesome
i don't even know what night that is
that might be in dallas if i'm not
mistaken yeah i think that's dallas and
that is what's that that's uh that's
west palm that was opening night with
don jr in west palm and and just
hundreds of people at every event the
energy was awesome people were laughing
i was throwing t-shirts into the crowd
people were going bananas it was just
absolutely great we got a couple more
tour stops coming up in about a week and
a half i will be in brea california with
dennis prager larry elder in oxnard
california douglas murray san jose blake
masters in phoenix brian callan in
denver they're all almost close to sold
out uh so there's a couple tickets left
i think i'm pretty sure all the vips are
already sold out and
that gives me an opportunity to make the
big announcement the big announcement
are we ready for the big announcement
you guys in your chairs everyone's all
right i got a fist bump i got a i got a
thumbs up the big announcement now you
may remember
people that originally we were gonna do
we were gonna kick off the entire
tour in orlando florida that was the
original thing and then i suddenly said
oh but something's happening we're gonna
have to move the date things are
happening a lot of people bought tickets
people were freaking out they were what
happened dave what's going on why aren't
you going to orlando
now if dave rubin says something and
then dave rubin has to you know say i'm
going to be here on this given day and
then dave reuben moves that day you know
that dave rubin has got something up his
sleeve you know what dave rubin's got up
his sleeve have you heard of this guy
governor ron desantis of the free state
of florida let's show them the image
people that's right dave rubin and
governor ron desantis will be at the
plaza live it's a huge theater about a
thousand seats
june 2nd
in orlando florida you can go to
daverubin.com
events to get tickets and it is
officially the last stop of the official
tour
and the governor will be there with me
look at those two smiles look at those
guys and maybe i'm going to say gay in
front of him
people are going to freak out it's very
exciting so yes that is why we moved the
orlando date i'm super psyched about
this obviously so i'll do my usual spiel
and get people laughing and all that
good stuff and then we're just gonna
have a completely no-holds-barred
conversation uh with the governor about
absolutely everything i think it's
awesome that it just happened to work
out that we're gonna do this in orlando
i mean that is the home of the mouse
right that is that is disney orlando
florida so we're going right to the
belly of the beast that's by total
coincidence actually too uh we did not
set it up that way but it the the world
works in mysterious ways as they say so
i am super psyched you can get your
tickets daverubin.com
events it is one month from today we've
known about it for a little while but
they do not release his schedule until
one month before where he's going to be
so it is one month from today june 2nd
in the year 2022 desantis reuben they
have made it very clear i can ask him
absolutely anything there is nothing off
limits this is 100 live we will be
recording it and then airing it on the
channel and all that good stuff and and
again it was just so great being out
there with you good people and i have to
say a lot of people said to me dave i
miss you miss you in studio miss the
show i'd say well you're with me right
now that's pretty good uh but i too
i missed it man you know every day i'm
going through twitter whatever i'm doing
online and normally what i'm doing is
i'm just sending my guys stuff for
tomorrow's show you know here's a clip
of biden having a mental breakdown
here's kamalabi it's stupid here's aoc's
insane here's nancy pelosi should be put
away and uh and i had nothing to do with
those clips because we didn't do shows
although we did put up a bunch of best
doves uh if you haven't seen them we put
a best of uh tucker carlson best of
jordan peterson i think we did a shapiro
and a couple others and uh that brings
me to today's show because it is dense
as i said a lot of paper here i am super
psyched and i think i called this first
and and i do want credit on this one the
day the book came out
was right around when elon musk was
starting to say he was going to buy
twitter and i was saying
something good is happening we are
seeing something
be birthed right in front of our eyes
but you gotta see it and that thing is
the post-woke world and a lot of good
stuff has happened in these last two
weeks not only did elon musk get twitter
last time i saw you guys in studio he
didn't officially have it he got twitter
the mask mandate on the planes went down
so i breathed freely on the planes i
didn't have to sip small amounts of
hazelnut creamer the oh i have to have
it for four hours do you have french
vanilla i need that too
i was breathing freely it was wonderful
uh good things are happening all over
the place hit pieces aren't working
anymore there's there's so much goodness
and
that is my mission for the next 40 or so
minutes with you fine people
and one more time just throw up that
image one more time it's me it's ron
desantis it's june 2nd it's going to be
a bonanza blowout right in mickey's
backyard at the plaza live in orlando
you can come see us we have a similar
both of us do the uh the eyes squint a
little on the smile thing there that's
that that'll be the theme of what we're
doing over there very excited about all
of this and yes i'm just super happy to
be back in studio and i missed you guys
too and we got a big show for you so
here we go uh first though quick guys i
want to talk to you about moik box i
love meat did you know that and i like
knowing exactly where my meat comes from
and with moyk that place is small family
farms across the country you can help
save the family farm and get access to
the highest quality meat on earth when
you join the moyk movement today that's
moo plus oink moic delivers grass-fed
and grass-finished beef and lamb
pasteurized pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught alaskan salmon
straight to your door you choose the
meat delivered in every box plus you can
cancel any time moik farmers farm like
our grandparents did and as a result the
moic difference is the difference you
can taste because the family farm does
it better and you can feel good knowing
you're helping family farms stay
financially independent as well
i just made some of the bone-in rib eyes
on the smoker and man they are good and
you know who agrees with me shark tank
host kevin o'leary he called moyk's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and ring doorbell founder jamie simenov
jumped at the chance to invest in moin
plus they guarantee you'll say oink oink
how about that sizzle sound for you
people that was good uh you'll say oink
oink i'm just so happy i got moint i
know i am and i know you will be too
keep american farming uh by going and
signing up to moicbox.com
reuben right now and listeners of this
show get a free filet mignon in every
order for a year that's one of the best
filet mignons you'll ever taste but for
a limited time spelled m-o-i-n-k
box.com
reuben that's moicbox.com reuben and now
back to me
a lot of talking for a guy that hasn't
been in studio for a while all right so
the big thing of course that happened
over the last two weeks a lot of big
things happen and the system fought back
against a lot of the good things we'll
get to that in a moment but the big
thing that officially happened because
we were all dancing around it for about
two weeks is that elon musk the founder
of tesla the founder of spacex the tony
stark of our time and whether you agree
with him on everything politically or
not is irrelevant the guy who is the
richest man on earth decided to put his
money where his mouth is and get
involved in the free speech fight and he
officially has twitter so we've got some
details from the daily wire twitter
announced late on monday that it has
entered a definitive agreement to be
acquired by elon musk for
54.20 per share in a deal valued at 44
million the transaction was unanimously
approved by twitter's board and is
expected to close this year subject to
the approval of twitter's shareholders
and other regulatory approval under the
terms of the agreement twitter
stockholders will receive 5420 in cash
for each share of twitter common stock
that they own upon closing of the
proposed transaction twitter said in a
statement the purchase price represents
a 38
premium to quit to twitter's closing
stock price on april 1 2022 which was
the last trading day before musk
disclosed
not
the board available owned less than one
percent
of the company was going to ensure that
elon musk could not buy the company they
were going to take this poison pill in
essence for every share that he bought
they would issue more shares so he could
never gain control of the company even
though he was paying this crazy premium
on it now that makes you wonder what was
the board trying to hide if the board is
not in the business of making money and
selling to the highest bidder then what
business are they in that's a question
that i think still should be asked of
all of those board members but
eventually i think what happened uh was
that an awful lot of shareholders
probably called their lawyers
and then those lawyers probably called
the lawyers of the board members and
said you better sell this freaking thing
to the richest man in the world who
wants to uh do more with it than you
guys have been doing because the stock
has basically been flat until he got
involved with his nine percent and then
the stock started jumping so something
good happened here shareholders fought
the board and eventually the board
capitulated and now there's going to be
a whole bunch of good things happening
because i think we're going to start
finding out some of the ways that
twitter has been manipulating us
but iwan has already started explaining
why he wanted to get into the fight for
free speech and purchase twitter it's
very important for
there to be
an inclusive arena for
free speech uh where
all yeah so uh yeah
um
twitter has become kind of the de facto
town square uh
it's just really important that people
have the both the uh the reality and the
perception
uh that they are able to speak freely
within the bounds of the law um
and
you know so one of the things that i
believe twitter should do is open source
the algorithm
um and make any changes
uh to people's tweets you know if
they're emphasized or de-emphasized uh
that action should be
made apparent so you can anyone can see
that action has been taken so there's no
sort of behind the scenes uh
manipulation either algorithmically or
manually all right so what's amazing
about this is all the guys talking about
is free speech hey we should have more
transparency related to the algorithm
people should be able to speak freely
within the confines of the law i'm not
going to manipulate this thing
politically or otherwise that's why i
want to get in but the reaction to elon
musk getting twitter has been completely
insane by all of the people that
seemingly want to control and manipulate
all of you all of the blue check people
and the washington post journalists the
paper owned by another billionaire jeff
bezos they're all freaking out all he's
saying is let's even the playing field
but there's a certain set of people that
don't want an even playing field i would
like an even playing field you guys you
like an even playing field all right
everybody nodded even playing field that
would be good let this place become the
new de facto times square what what we
have what we used to have was that there
would be a place right the public square
times square is a type of public square
i suppose there would be a public square
in each town in america and this is
where you could get up on a box and you
could yell and if people wanted to
listen they would listen and if they
didn't want to listen they didn't have
to and if you had righteous indignation
and a cause you could actually get out
there and say what you want to say right
like that's that's what the public
square is all about and as long as you
are not calling for violence and then
the few other things that limit our free
speech like libel and slander things
like that you're good to go
um twitter became that thing and look we
all may hate twitter to a degree you
know my feelings i have a very love hate
thing with it it's a time suck and the
algorithms have manipulated us in the
shadow banning all that stuff but it has
become the way we communicate and the
taste makers and the politicians and the
culturally relevant people communicate
it just is so we needed it to be fairer
we needed it to be be something that
would not manipulate the results of an
election say by hiding a story like the
hunter biden laptop story say by
depressing the amount of followers that
people could get my guys just told me
right now so in about three days after
uh elon musk bought twitter one of the
things that people started noticing is
people on the right you're not going to
believe the scary people on the right
their followers started exploding
exploding uh and people on the left
their followers started dumping out so i
got about a hundred thousand new
followers on twitter in about three days
uh i'm told ben shapiro got about four
hundred thousand and then we started
seeing people on the left disappear now
is that because they're suddenly
deleting all their bots that faked all
of their influence that might be
something are they burning the documents
are they shredding stuff over there what
is elon going to uncover well
i'm a man of the world and i went on the
twitter machine and i tweeted at elon
musk and he actually responded i said
hey elon musk as long as you're digging
check into how the new york times forbes
etc bought their twitter followers to
fake influence new york times has 53
million followers and rarely gets 50
retweets i could post a banana emoji and
a picture of an 80s sitcom star and get
more and then i followed it up and this
is my this might be my greatest moment
as a as a broadcaster and a public
person i then tweeted out a banana emoji
and of course that is sophia petrillo
played by the wonderful actress estelle
getty in the seminal sitcom the golden
girls which was aired on nbc on saturday
nights from 1985 to 1992 that got 63 000
likes uh and then elon musk did respond
to me and he said yeah i noticed too
pretty weird now you can sort of see why
the system was so against elon musk
getting this thing the new york times
supposedly 53
million followers but they rarely get 10
or even 20 retweets on anything they
have faked all of their influence all of
this time and that's why the reality you
see on the ground is so different than
the reality we see
online right like that is the disconnect
that everything that we're in this fight
over these last 20 years is that there
are there's a new set of trusted people
there is a new set of people that are
trying to bring some level of truth to
the world and then there are the old
decaying things that faked it through
money
and endless [ __ ] and a bunch of blue
check people who were willing to to play
their game who were just endlessly
willing to play their game uh but then
elon tweeted out this this image which
is really just spectacular so this is an
image uh he did not credit him but the
guy i've met the guy who did this his
name is colin wright
and he had made up this image from a
couple years ago and i just look at this
map
or this image for just a second and i
think this sums up where so many of us
are at right now so you can see
uh in 2008 elon musk and he's basically
saying that this is him right so you can
see the me guy
is sort of a little bit left of center
and that the fellow liberal yeah he's a
little bit maybe left of him but that
elon saying hey i was a little bit left
of center in 2008. then four years later
in 2012 what happened the fellow liberal
the lefties the progressives they all
went bananas do you think i know a
little something about this was there a
guy like me maybe i'm a guy like me
screaming about this for years while
left the left etc etc and that the left
just went bananas left crazy
then flash forward nine more years and
then you've got the woke progressives
and they are extremely far left now and
what that did was push a guy this is
like what elon musk is saying about
himself it pushed a guy like elon musk
to basically be center right and then
the conservative over there on the right
is just loling like c c we were right
all along those people are bananas i
would say me personally i'm probably a
little bit closer to the lol guy than to
even where elon musk puts himself on
this 2021 um
you know spot but that's sort of
irrelevant what he's hitting on there
and the fact that he even put that out
is he's saying hey
me as a guy
that wants to defend free speech where
does that put me
on this right where does this put me on
this line of political
stuff political polarity well if you
basically defend free speech
you're pretty much on the right right
now you're pretty much conservative
right now
if you want to defend america you're
pretty much on the right right now
you're pretty much a conservative right
now that's just how it is now of course
there is another liberal out there an
old school liberal who gets it on one
day then doesn't get it the next day and
seemingly uh makes some sense and then
makes no sense we've talked about him a
lot and i've got a video here of him
getting it and also kind of not getting
it
bill maher ladies and gentlemen you know
what the babylon bee is
i didn't know this no it's like the
christian version of the onion
because everyone needs that well some
people do i thought that was not all you
and me okay it says your trusted source
for christian news and satire i didn't
know it was such a thing as christian
satire
i thought the religion itself was
satisfied that's me
i'm not everybody
okay
i'm not everybody have a little humility
so listen to this they got flagged
for
they posted a funny video this is funny
to them okay
sensitive content twitter said in the
video they were making fun of twitter
for being too sensitive this is so
through the looking glass and here's
what happens in the video this woman who
going into the twitter building this is
you know parody this is what people do
on television have done forever
okay
she's complaining to hr about how
sensitive twitter is and the guy shows
her an inkblot and she keeps seeing
hitler and all the inkblots
okay then she runs screaming out of the
building because she's
this is sad this is well within what
satire has always been
and the fact that they flagged us for
being insensitive shows their complete
lack of self-awareness about what their
own problem is if that's where the line
is you have failed twitter you do need a
new show
all right so bill moore
once again you pretty much get it now
he's also showing that he doesn't get it
he didn't even know what babylon b was
until they presented him with that
segment so it sure it sort of shows you
that he's out of touch of what actually
is kind of funny right now and relevant
and edgy and everything else but he does
something really nice there
uh when the other guy the msnbc guy
what's that ali velshi when he's like ah
who needs it like who needs christian
satire and bill maher even though he has
spent an entire career making fun of
christianity and making fun of organized
religion he says not everybody is me
have a little bit of humility that
actually is a really nice moment that's
actually a really human moment for bill
maher so credit where credit is due for
sure and then of course credit where
credit is due which is that he's
defending satire now unfortunately he
hasn't been screaming about all of the
other censorship that twitter has been
doing for years but again
i i suppose at this point the five last
remaining good liberals are just slow
motion conservatives that's what they
are and i guess we just have to take it
that's okay and maybe they'll fully get
there
you know my feelings on all of that well
then there is this crazy lady who lies
for a living she is the number one liar
in america and she soon will be stepping
down from her lying over at the white
house to to lie officially every day on
the clown network known as msnbc of
course i am talking about gensake oh and
by the way during the uh the live shows
that i did on tour every time i said
sake on stage people had to drink people
were often wasted five minutes into the
show it was fantastic uh but gen saki
she's very concerned that elon musk and
his desire for free speech and an even
public square in a place where people
can express their own views without
government overreach that's gonna that's
no good we can't have that does the
white house have any concern that this
new agreement might have president trump
back on the platform well i'm not going
to comment on a specific transaction uh
what i can tell you is a general matter
no matter who owns or runs
twitter the president has long been
concerned about the power of large
social media platforms uh what they had
that power they have over our everyday
lives has long argued that tech
platforms must be held accountable for
the harms they cause he has been a
strong supporter of fundamental reforms
to achieve that goal including reforms
to section 230 enacting anti-trust
reforms requiring more transparency and
more and he's encouraged uh that there's
bipartisan interest in congress in terms
of what hypothetical policies uh might
happen i'm just not going to speak to
that at this point oh that [ __ ] is
freaking out you can feel it you can
feel it you see they're losing control
of the narrative they're losing that's
what's happening right here this is all
good today's show i really want you to
understand that this is all
good elon musk's got it he got the
twitter machine he's opening it up and
maybe orangeman will be back i heard
mike lindell my pillow guy he was back
for a few minutes then he left again but
the point is they're opening this up and
what freaks out this administration and
the people that want to control you more
than anything else what freaks them out
is that you might have a thought and you
might get that thought out there and
that thought might be against them okay
her line there tech must be held
accountable for their harms how about
the harms that you people that you
freaks have been
smashing us with for the last year with
the economy and the rest of the nonsense
and gas prices and supply chain et
cetera et cetera et cetera so what's gen
saki and old joe biden going to do about
it well the big news of last week and i
was really like i got to get back in
studio for this one they've uh they've
got a ministry of truth we truly are in
1984. they've got a czar and this woman
who's going to be in charge of
disinformation in america this is an
assault on the first amendment like
never before and i'm fairly certain that
if an orange man had done this we'd be
in the middle of an impeachment already
but here is sake
defending the ministry of truth i think
what's important to note here is what
the board is doing which is continuing
what is important disinformation related
work that began under the former
administration the fact sheet that they
put out what they noted yesterday what
they noted in there is that this is
meant to uh won the first bullet was
about protecting privacy civil rights
and civil liberties and the first
amendment they said the primary mission
is to establish best practices to to to
ensure that efforts to understand and
respond to disinformation are done in
ways that protect privacy civil rights
and civil liberties i'd also note that
the first example they gave about what
they're going to do is uh is support the
department of homeland security's work
ongoing work back to the former
administration on to address how and
understand how misinformation spread by
human smugglers that prey on vulnerable
populations attempting to migrate to the
united states
you people are terrible but we're
winning that's the point okay so what
you they're doing here is now they've
got their ministry of disinformation and
they're going to try to con conflate it
with somehow terrorist activities and
human smuggling and all these scary
things but what they really mean is you
you person watching this and me sitting
right here they mean people that speak
up again against them the first
amendment defends your ability to speak
freely the idea that the government now
has an agency i mean this is 1984.
or welly and double speak with this
woman
the idea that the government has now
decided we're going to look at
disinformation and see what people can i
can't say this is an assault on the
first amendment the free speech war is
here we seemingly were out of covid now
right we wrapped that thing up nicely
that was fun uh now the free speech war
is here and you better decide what side
you're on that's that's really where
we're at with all of this stuff um the
government cannot do this i mean i guess
they can do it until we say you can't do
it but just be very clear on what they
mean by disinformation uh very fine
people trump remember that that was
disinformation that they spread if you
if you get the vaccine you won't get
coveted that was disinformation that
they spread uh brett kavanaugh's a
serial rapist that was this information
that they spread uh kyle
rittenhouse is racist that was
disinformation that they spread the
covenant kids are racist that was
disinformation that they spread jesse
smellette that was this information that
they spread they lie about everything
their entire machine is built on lying
about absolutely everything and what
they are trying to do is make you afraid
of saying anything about it but it ain't
gonna work much longer and by the way
don't think it's a coincidence it is not
a coincidence that elon musk buys
twitter and says hey we'd like to
respect free speech we'd like to have
more voices on here and as long as
you're not breaking the law you're good
to go and then basically within 24 hours
the ministry of truth appears out of
nowhere right out of the ether how did
that happen do you think that's a
coincidence i think not
and you may remember this guy
this uh barack obama guy do you remember
this barack obama guy he was a president
before the orange man and uh now that he
uh is not president anymore but he's
sort of president cause joe biden's
obviously not in charge he wants to make
sure that censorship is uh happening
everywhere yeah now the good news is is
that almost all the big tech platforms
now acknowledge some responsibility for
content on their platforms and they're
investing in large teams of people to
monitor it
given the sheer volume of content this
strategy can feel like a game of
whack-a-mole
still
in talking to people at these companies
i believe they are sincere in trying to
limit content that engages
in hate speech encourages violence or
poses a threat to public safety
they genuinely are concerned about it
they want to
do something about it
but
while content moderation
can limit the distribution of clearly
dangerous content
it doesn't go far enough
more censorship from barack obama and
the administration he wants more and
more and more and more now what did he
say there that was really interesting
well first off there's the subtext to
what he's saying notice he's only
concerned about what you say online
notice these people never concerned
about the lies of the mainstream media
all the stories that i just referenced
30 seconds ago they never like oh we
really botched that one somebody's going
to get fired for that one we really lied
about that one or we really hid that one
they're not concerned about mainstream
media's lies they're concerned about
your lies and what they mean by your
lies or you are the truth not your truth
the truth but he said something very
dangerous there
he says that they want to limit hate
speech violence blah blah now the hate
speech part is the key to this thing if
you post a violent threat on twitter the
law is now involved right if you say i'm
going to come and kill you or i'm going
to blow up that building or a litany of
other truly direct violent threats we
have laws around those things but what
he says and what he wants is that he
wants them to limit hate speech
now first off the supreme court has
decided there is no such thing as hate
speech right because one person's hate
speech is another person's free speech
people say awful things to me all day
long on twitter all day long now first
off there's a button you can press and i
press the button i think it was a swipe
actually
with the quality filter and i just
swiped it once and now i don't see 99 of
it right you just don't i don't know how
the algorithm works i don't know what
they did there i probably miss a lot of
people saying nice things about me too
but that's okay i clicked that and then
you know what you do i i've found that
there are there are nodes of people that
can instigate a lot of hate so there's a
lot of like big name lefties that hate
me right so all i did was there's about
10 of them let's say i just block them
and then if you block them they can't
direct all of their people over to you i
didn't force anyone to be censored
that's what i did but i get tons of hate
hate comes my way all the time uh and i
don't ask for anyone to be censored
right if they were directly threatening
my life now we got a bigger problem and
again we already have laws about that
stuff so obama's intentionally doing
something here because he wants you to
think that if you say anything against
this regime if you dare fight the
ministry of truth and the rest of it
that you're engaged in hate they're just
amplifying everything they have done
against all of us for years anyone who's
a conservative if you supported trump
and eventually it'll be if you support
desantis and everything else that you're
a hater and you should be censored
because that's hate speech even though
hate speech doesn't exist and again
remember they never are concerned about
the nonsense and the lies that the
mainstream media push out it's always us
uh but then yesterday what was yesterday
it was the no it was saturday night was
the white house correspondents dinner
and this is basically where
the sort of i would say marginal swamp
creatures of the media they call it nerd
prom
this is where these people
get together and they put on tuxedos and
they basically fellate fellate is that a
word fellate not filet
you get it you get it they massage thank
you phoenix they massage the president
of the united states because he's a
democrat so they like him so they mostly
make fun of republicans the entire time
uh here's biden he he gave a little uh
pre-written joke statement during the
special threat climate change
free fast is not the enemy the people
far from it
at your best
your guardians of the truth
president kennedy once said and i quote
without debate
without criticism
no
administration no country can succeed
and no republicans survive
the first amendment
grants a free press extraordinary
protection
but with it comes
as many of you know a very heavy
obligation
to seek the truth as best you can
not to inflame or entertain
but to illuminate and educate
oh man this old windbag nobody's
listening anymore dude nobody's
listening and you know what why because
you're pretending that the media is
honest and good you're pretending that
the media would hold you to account
you're pretending that the media isn't
all in on it with your political party
and at the same time you're talking
about the first amendment you're pushing
for your ministry of truth to censor the
people the people who are against you
but thank god we've got some people
right now who are feeling good and who
are fighting it and you know how you
continue to fight it you continue to
fight it by every time they push more of
their nonsense and they have to escalate
the nonsense i think this is where we're
at right now
enough of us are seeing it we're all
seeing it right now so they have to keep
escalating that's all they can do with
the nonsense this is that scene remember
that scene in v for vendetta if you
haven't seen for a while when uh supreme
chancellor suttler when he's like he's
like we have to show the people how much
they need us that's that's where we're
in uh that's where we're at right now
but they want this ministry of truth so
here's a little bit of that unbiased and
fair corporate press that we've got
defending the ministry of truth here's
dhs secretary mayorkus on uh c
n
n
republicans are criticizing
your decision the administration's
decision to choose nina jankowicz to
lead this disinformation board they say
she is not somebody who is neutral your
response eminently qualified a renowned
expert in the field of disinformation
absolutely so eminently qualified a
renowned expert in that thing of
disinformation
um what eminently qualified for what to
stamp down on our free speech rights
eminently qualified for a nonsensical
organization a nonsensical board that
you people she's qualified to stop
people from talking can't you tell she's
quality i went to college
awful humans uh awful awful humans uh
but they're they're freaking out and why
are they freaking out because we're
starting to be freed
we're starting to be freed and it has
something to do with that twitter thing
we've been talking about uh so here i
think we've got uh is this stelter this
is stelter and he's freaking out because
they've got the board but but we can
still speak freely on twitter look who
knows i i think that's a that's a that's
a an example of a broader question for
twitter which is if you uh
if you get invited to something where
there are no rules where there is total
freedom forever everybody do you
actually want to go to that party or are
you gonna decide to stay home and that's
a question for twitter users some
twitter users might love the idea
there's gonna be absolutely no
moderation and no rules at all others
might not want to be anywhere near that
am i am i crazy matt no no you're right
and what what happens to the advertising
i mean if there's no moderation or
little moderation do the advertisers
stay away what does that do to the
business prospects for twitter i think
what we learned right there is that
brian stelter has never been invited to
a party has anyone in the history of the
world ever been like honey honey we're
having that party tonight let's invite
everybody you want to have the
stealthers over
nobody's ever yes yes let's have the
stealthers over they're fun
horrible human be oh no a place where
people might get to speak freely oh and
people are gonna have to decide if they
want to go to that no i'd rather go to
your party stelter
but speaking of uh here's liz warren do
you think it is clear that elon musk
will be
pro-conservatives or republican party in
the united states or do you think that's
a misreading of him
you know
for me that's frankly not the most
interesting question i mean it's it's he
could be one way or the other and it
would still be wrong
the problem is one of power and
concentrated power it's about one person
making all of the decisions about how
tens of millions of people will have an
opportunity to communicate with each
other
that's where the problem is
she should have played an evil
high school teacher in a horrible 80s
movie that's really what she is she's so
conflating things that she knows
understand all he's saying is free
speech
it is possible that one man could come
in and do a good job with something now
what she really fears is that elon musk
is not a big government suck-up right
he's gotten some benefits from the
government by the way i think he's i
think he's more libertarian-leaning but
if the government offers you subsidies
for your companies you take those
subsidies if there's places you can move
your companies to pay less taxes you
move to those places what she does not
like about elon musk there's two things
there's one that he won't just bow to
government forever but it's also that
he's just saying free speech and there
is nothing that lefties hate more than
an equal playing field they only win
they only win when they can silence you
they only win when they confuse you as
to what the issues are and when they can
use all of their propaganda to make you
think that up is down and left is right
and boys are girls and two plus two is
five and everything else and that's what
we're all now seeing and what's
interesting about all of this is that
they're nonsensical games are no longer
working so some of you may have seen
this over the last couple days the new
york times the failing somebody there
was an orange man who used to call it
the failing new york times he was right
about a lot of stuff it turns out
the failing new york times all they've
got left are lies and hit pieces so they
ran this
just this bananas hit piece on tucker
carlson just really just ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous hit piece and the
thing is it doesn't convince anyone yes
they've got their little sliver of blain
brainwashed blue npc people that read it
and think that tucker carlson's a nazi
but everyone else just mocks the [ __ ]
out of it and they're actually aiding
and abetting in their own destruction
it's quite beautiful but tucker's doing
the right thing doing the right thing in
the post-woke world which is that you
mock them you fight back and you
continue to do good work tucker carlson
this has got to be the 10th or 27th or
217th story just like this the new york
times has run and all of them are pretty
much identical racist racist racist
the latest version of the story is being
written by a kid called nick confessore
confessory seems a little more
self-important than most of them but
essentially he's the same as the last
guy and the guy before him because on
some level all these guys are the same
they're obedient little establishment
defenders who will say anything to
please their bosses they're suck-ups
brown nosers lick spittles
not people you'd want to have dinner
with anyway the new york times is
calling us racist again and we're still
in the air which shows you how well it
works
but you've got to wonder
why they keep doing this
if you wanted to criticize this show
there are plenty of things you could say
we've got a ton of supposedly
controversial opinions on a million
different topics we talk about them
every night
big finance is wrecking america
marijuana actually isn't medicine
russiagate is totally idiotic and so is
the war it's now causing feminism is a
corporate lie marriage makes you happy
so does raising your own children and so
on even think ufos are real
so in some ways by the standards the new
york times were pretty far out but they
never mention any of that
and the funny thing is the one thing we
do not have exotic opinions on is race
our view of race is really simple we
believe martin luther king
we don't think your skin color is the
most important thing about you we think
all people were created by god and
should therefore be judged by what they
do
not by how they look
okay so new york times runs this piece
uh tucker does the right thing which is
calmly uh fight back but then he did
this on twitter which this really is it
shows you where the shift is occurring
he just had someone take a picture of
him probably his wife at home with that
[ __ ] eating grin holding the new york
times which he should be wiping his ass
with
the front page hit piece on him and that
is where we are at this is how you win
you have better ideas you calmly explain
yourself and you mock these freaks and
then you build a better world that's
what you got to do by the way that's
what we're doing right here in florida
and that will bring us uh to the next
portion of the show big show today guys
we're 40 minutes in big show
ron desantis over here in florida who by
the way you can see with me yours truly
on june 2nd in orlando at the plaza live
get tickets at daverubin.com events well
ron desantis also uh knows a little
something about the hit pieces the same
way that they ran all of that stuff on
tucker for years and they uh for on
trump for years and now they run it on
tucker and they've done it on guys like
me and jordan peterson and ben shapiro
and a whole bunch of others let's not
forget the new york times did once put
my picture on the front of the sunday
paper saying that i lead people to the
alt-right me it was me jordan peterson
ben shapiro milton friedman and thomas
sull great people great people
but desantis is also firing back on this
ministry of truth nonsense because
everyone knows this has nothing to do
with truth it has everything to do with
propaganda
but clearly
uh our entire
principles that the country was founded
on
you cannot have a ministry of truth in
this country and so let's get real here
let's let's make sure that we're doing
things to benefit uh floridians and
americans uh but we're not gonna let
biden get away with this one so we'll be
fighting back
yeah we're not gonna let him get away
with it we're gonna fight back we're
gonna mock them we're gonna probably
pass laws to make sure that the
rights of americans and your ability to
protest the government and speak freely
uh will be strengthened here in a place
like florida because we're winning our
playbook is working the things that
desantis has been fighting for and that
tucker has been fighting for and that
elon musk has been fighting for it's all
working we're getting post-woke so
they're getting more hysterical they're
getting more hysterical and what have i
been saying for a while and what is this
freaking book about it's about you
versus the system the system is is
trying to scare the [ __ ] out of you now
that we've gotten past up there there we
go we got demonetized no lunch for you
guys today but the system is trying to
scare you guys you get it the more that
they do this craziness it's designed to
scare you again because the covid thing
the fear of covid thing is starting to
dissipate so they need new fear and now
the new fear is don't say stuff because
we've got a ministry of truth
but one man can beat it elon's one guy
desantis is one guy judge mizell the
tampa federal judge who reversed the
mandate is one person all tucker is one
guy and then i saw this one guy who i
think is just great he's just great he
was on the glenn beck program uh
discussing uh desantis elon musk and the
rest of it look disney lost 41 billion
dollars in the last three weeks and why
did it lose it because they've been
infected and then one man ron de santa
said no more
and that that i love the idea that one
man elon musk is one man now he may be
an extraordinary person and he's the
tony stark of our time and it's hard to
imagine a guy sending tesla's into space
but he's one guy one guy who could have
done whatever he wanted if he wanted to
put his family on a rocket tomorrow and
disappear from earth and all of our
mortal problems gone he could do it but
instead he got into the biggest fight
possible the free speech fight elon musk
is one guy
ron desantis is one guy judge mizell the
35 year old female trump appointed judge
in tampa who just said nope no more mask
mandates and then what happens
everybody rips them off covet isn't
going crazy for the last two weeks
one woman so we just need the individual
to say no to the machine
the individual to say no to the machine
but you have to really know what you're
doing you have to know what they're
doing and then you have to know how you
are going to fight back now you might
have heard of this uh they tell me five
foot nine orthodox jew they five foot
nine i think five foot eight seems well
whatever it is uh this ben shapiro fell
over at the uh the daily wire uh he had
a great little rant he does his little
fast talking rants he is also a new
floridian by the way uh he basically
laid out what republicans have to do
to fight back one of the fears that i
think a lot of conservatives have and
it's a perennial fear is that the
republican party somehow gains power
again nationally speaking and then
doesn't do its job it always feels as
though the ratchet only works one way
that the best that republicans can do is
sort of the william f buckley routine
you stand on the rails of history
shouting stop but it turns out the train
just keeps sort of moving you down the
track maybe just a little bit more
slowly and when you look at how the
republican party in the past has treated
power you do see that you see the
republican party spending enormous
amounts of money you see the republican
party shying away from the most
important cultural battles i mean you've
taken a lot of these battles head-on but
there are many other governors who are
republicans who have run screaming from
these battles gone national television
criticized you for for taking part in
that battle
how do you think the republican party
needs to change in order to become more
of a fighting party for conservatives
well look i'm doing the best i can for
the people the state that's what
motivates me but we're on offense and
we're not just going to sit there
and let the left define the agenda we're
not going to let the media define the
agenda we are going out and we are
getting in front of issues that matter
to people and i'm able to do that
partially because since i've been
governor i have not taken a single poll
i don't know i just know i grew up here
i was raised here i was born here
i know the folks i get out every day in
different communities and talk to people
and i know what i believe and so my job
as a leader is to set the course
execute on my vision and if you do that
successfully people will get your back
people will follow and so that's a
different model i think than the typical
republican has had because i think
they're always so gun-shy about oh well
if we do this the media is going to
criticize us you know when i was in
congress they wouldn't send subpoenas
about things like the irs scandal
because they were worried about the
media criticizing them for overreach and
i thought to myself like this is nuts
you're neutering your own yourselves so
i think what these republicans have to
understand is you cannot let corporate
media
curtail your agenda that you cannot be
worried about what they're going to say
these are bad faith actors they are not
operating in ways that are fair and
their whole job is to try to concoct
narratives that are going to benefit our
political opponents and that are going
to kneecap our own agenda so what i
don't do is i do not respond to
corporate media pressure i don't respond
to corporate media criticism heck the
way i view it is if they're criticizing
me i must be over the target i must be
doing something right and that's just
how we have to be
you feel it guys this is how we win he
is one
man and he ain't going anywhere how do i
know he said it himself i don't care
what corporate media outlets say i don't
care what hollywood says i don't care
what big corporations say
here i stand
i'm not backing down
yeah here i am and guess what here i am
and there's tucker carlson and there's
ben shapiro and there you are whatever
you do in your life to say enough is
enough vote all of these people out do
not give them your respect
or your money or your attention or
anything else and thus we will win
i think this is the longest show we've
ever done we're at basically 50 minutes
right now this is very exciting i'm
feeling good i go for another seven
eight hours but uh before we get to the
cold close i want to get to some uh
local comments uh olaf says i wonder if
twitter has been cooking their books
well that's what we're gonna find out
right like how did i suddenly get a
hundred thousand followers in three days
when i normally get about 500 followers
how am i suddenly seeing a whole bunch
of people in my feed that i used to not
see i mean if elon really unearths this
just think of the ways we may have been
manipulated i'm not talking about the
obvious stuff like whatever they did
related to the hunter bite and laptop
and whether emails are going to come out
that the administration the oncoming
administration or the obama
administration or whatever else whatever
whatever lackeys and government agents
may have had connections at twitter i'm
talking about all of the other stuff
were employees reading dms were people
being shadow banned in ways that you
just never saw anything anymore did they
suppress certain stories is that
happening on youtube right now i have no
doubt i have no doubt that they can push
you to believe certain things and they
can hide other things and a whole bunch
more so this stuff is coming out and
that's why we now have a ministry of
truth do you get it the stuff's coming
out the people are seeing it and they
can't have the people seeing it and
that's really what this is all about all
of this this everything we've talked
about today is that some people are
waking up and going boy
it sure does seem like something weird's
been going on around here i'd like to
talk about it with some of my other
fellow citizens and then there's a whole
bunch of people
that are going no no no no we know
better than you we've got uh what what
did mayorka say about her she's well
qualified and she's good and you know
you're going to be good
patrick says notice how the
conservatives on elon's diagram stayed
in the same place unlike the left we
have remained true to our principles
that's interesting if can we throw that
image up again for just one second
so elon tweeted out the image we'll get
it for you in just a sec there you go
that the conservatives basically stayed
in the same place now what's interesting
is i think you can argue that over the
years the conservatives actually
moved somewhat leftward in that say on
gay rights or on gay marriage right that
we thought of that as a left thing now i
think you can also argue it from a right
perspective like just stay out of my
bedroom but in essence the conservatives
pretty much did stay roughly the same or
maybe a little bit to the left and
that's what having principles is all
about if you have some principles then
regardless of whether a democrat's in
office or a republican's in office
you'll still know what you believe the
left has decided that all of their
principles are only based in who is in
power and how they can attain power so
you can get them to do crazy things and
constantly say crazy things and be
completely bananas and then bring in a
ministry of truth to defend it but we
will win
david great name says can't wait to see
desantis in orlando i just purchased my
tickets awesome looking forward to
seeing you
it's going to be a great night and as i
said he specifically told us nothing is
off limits i'll do my talk he'll do his
talk the belly of the beast right in
disney's home country maybe they'll send
some of the he she genderless uh
disney employees they're welcome to come
too i'll put them up in the front row if
they want to come that'll be fun
you can get your tickets at
daverubin.com
events
big show people oh if you didn't catch
it i put up an interview last week that
we had shot the week before we shot it
actually in my house because douglas
murray one of the great thinkers that
we've got on this planet earth was here
in miami and i really wanted to do it in
person so we shot it in my house uh
british conservative author douglas
murray his new book war the war on the
west is out right now the full episode
is up on youtube and on rumble and of
course on blaze tv
and uh wow 53 minutes we set a reuben
report record one month from today by
the way i'll be in orlando with ron
desantis in case you hadn't heard and
we're back in business everybody's going
to have lunch today we got a whole bunch
more to do it's good to be back in
studio i look forward to seeing you guys
back out on the road in about two weeks
and uh our cold close because
you know if uh if i'm wrong about all
this at least we've got joe biden i'm
america god bless you
[Applause]
[Music]
you